good morning John I suppose I should
still be making these videos for you
even though you're not making them for
me it's part of this thing on tumblr I
almost read bond but that I figured no
this is good enough for a whole video
it's a piece of what appears to be a
science quiz it asks the question what
is the strongest force on earth and the
student has written love and the teacher
has crossed it out with a big red X well
I want to know what the greatest force
on earth actually is and also what the
teacher thinks it is and I just really
like to overanalyze stuff so let's do
that now first physicists will tell you
that there are in fact only four forces
in the universe space gravity which is
the obvious one that we feel all the
time cuz you know it's always trying to
make us fall over with super knowing
unless you're in bed in which case I'm
jealous gravity it turns out is actually
the weakest of the forces there's
actually electromagnetism the weak
nuclear force and the strong nuclear
force and as the name suggests the
strong nuclear force is the strongest
force it is 1 times 10 to the 39th times
stronger than gravity the people who
don't know scientific notation watch
crash course chemistry also it's a lot
so that's the answer the actual definite
answer to the question is it is the
strong force done right now not done
because probably at the student put that
down the teacher still would have put a
big red X through it and the question
above which mentions igneous and
sedimentary rocks I can assume that this
is a geology quiz and with that
information I'm going to guess that the
teacher is actually trying to ask what
thing has the greatest impact on the
Earth's geology and the answer that
they're looking for is water or the
hydrological cycle which yes has a huge
impact on the geology of the earth but
you can also make other cases you could
say that life has the greatest impact on
the geology of the earth by creating
soils and preventing erosion and
transpiring moisture into the atmosphere
the more interesting line of reasoning
for me is if you interpret the question
and yes it is open for interpretation
obviously because it is so poorly worded
not what has had the greatest impact on
the Earth's geology but what is
currently having the greatest impact on
the Earth's geology and in that case it
is very easy to make the case that the
answer to that question is humans humans
turn mountains inside up dry up lakes
turn deserts into gardens and forests
into deserts there's more to it than
that right like what is the force that
drives humans what is the reason why
there are so many humans on the planet
well my friends what is that force the
force that keeps us to get there keeps
us
feeding our children keeps us
coupling and making more it's love it's
love isn't it it's really it's sex it's
yeah but you could make the case that
the answer to the question the teacher
thinks that they are asking that they're
not actually asking is love and that my
friends is how to be su a into an a on a
geology test you have to say that that's
not the actual answer though because the
actual answer is the energy of the Sun
without which the hydrological cycle
trees and people would not exist John
and I were talking recently about how we
like to think that we understand this
community that we you know interact with
constantly but would probably really
don't at least not to it like a great
degree of accuracy so John and I decided
that it would be a good idea to do a
census of nerdfighteria whose link in
the description to a survey it's about
30 questions long it'll take 10 to 30
minutes and we would really really
appreciate it if you take the time to
fill it out Craig thank you for your
amazing video this week and grace I will
see you on Tuesday